depuis le début de la crise ducobu 19
beaucoup prônent le monde d'après qui
serait un nouveau monde meilleur que le
précédent
pourtant les chiffres ne trouve pas le
monde d'après ressemble plutôt au monde
d'avant plutôt au monde d'avant d'avant
même la crise sanitaire et c2
confinement ont mis l'économie mondiale
à genoux en france en termes de volumes
vendus et de clients annuels il faut
remonter loin dans le temps pour trouver
des niveaux semblables dans de nombreux
secteurs économiques
le journal les echos a recensé une
demi-douzaine de bond en arrière dans
l'automobile par exemple 1 8 million de
voitures neuves ont été achetées cette
année il faut remonter à 1975 pour
trouver un marché automobile aussi bas
dans l'hexagone
à l'époque un premier choc pétrolier
faisait flamber les prix des carburants
et a provoqué la dégringolade des
immatriculations l'achat de carburant en
chute libre également est cette année
les ventes d'essence et de gazole en
chuté de plus de 15% soit moins de 37
millions de mètres cubes selon l'union
française des industries pétrolières il
faut remonter à 1988 pour constater une
équivalence à l'époque elle l'hexagone
comptait 25 mille stations essence deux
fois plus qu'aujourd'hui on estime en
effet qu'en france la consommation
d'essence et de gasoil est actuellement
inférieure de 60 à 85% à la normale en
fonction des départements
il faut dire qu'entre le chômage partiel
et le télétravail nombre de français
n'ont plus besoin de prendre leur
voiture pour se rendre sur leur lieu de
travail confinement crise sanitaire et
frontière fermée ne rime pas beaucoup
avec vacances à l'étranger
le trafic aérien est en recul de 70%
depuis le début de l'année pour
retrouver un pareil niveau d'activité de
roissy charles de gaulle il faut
remonter à 1990 avec 23 millions de
passagers de grosses turbulences avaient
déjà secoué le secteur la première
guerre du golfe a par exemple provoquer
une baisse du trafic aérien
de 10% ce qui était énorme à ce
moment-là 2020 année terrible également
pour les salles obscures 64,9 millions
d'entrées cette année contre 200
millions par an ces dix dernières années
une chute de 62% par rapport à 2019 et
c'était du jamais vu depuis la fin de la
première guerre mondiale au début des
années 20 à l'époque le cinéma était
muet et diffusée en noir et blanc le 7e
art va donc devoir se renouveler
d'autant que le streaming et les vidéos
à la demande semble de plus en plus en
vogue
si même les block busters sorte à la
fois sur la plateforme de streaming et
en salle à quoi bon continuer d'aller au
cinéma est payé 15 dollars la place
alors que le public peut s'abonner à une
plateforme de streaming pour le même cri
c'est un signal pour les autres studios
la warner rond les règles de bonne
conduite qui étaient en vigueur dans
l'industrie du cinéma jusqu'à présent et
elle crée un précédent
au risque de faire passer les salles de
cinéma au second rang du modèle
économique derrière le streaming le
musée le plus visité du monde a vu ses
allées se vider habitué à accueillir
plus de 10 millions de visiteurs par an
le louvre a accueilli quatre fois moins
de curieux fin en 2020
il faut remonter à 1988 pourra retrouver
un niveau aussi bas
à l'époque le tourisme n'était pas
encore s'y développer le musée n'avait
pas ouvert dans sa totalité la pyramide
elle n'était même pas encore là vous
l'aurez compris 2020 aura été une année
noire pour l'économie française
mais compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire actuelle et de la découverte
récente d'une variante ducobu de 10,9 au
royaume-uni qu il ne présage rien de bon
non plus pour 2021